- Good afternoon, hello everyone.
My name is Dean Timeica Bethel,
I am Assistant Dean of Yale College
and director of the
Afro-American Cultural Center,
more affectionately known as The House,
AKA, this big beautiful building
you're sitting in right now.
So welcome home.
Before we begin now,
I would like to do the
land acknowledgement.
So Yale University acknowledges
that indigenous peoples and nations,
including the Mohegan,
the Mashantucket Pequot,
the Eastern Pequot, the Schaghticoke,
the Golden Hill Paugussett, the Niantic,
and the Quinnipiac, and other
Algonquian speaking peoples
have stewarded through
generations the land and waterways
of what is now the State of Connecticut
and where our university sits.
We honor and respect the
enduring relationship
that exists between these peoples
and nations and this land.
I would like to briefly tell you a bit
about The House before
our event begins today.
So the Afro-American Cultural
Center was founded in 1969
by three Yale undergraduates,
Don Ogilvie, Armstead
Robinson, and Glenn de Chabert.
They worked for two years
with local New Haven activists
and some professors on campus
to petition the University for a space
for Black students to call home
while they were here at Yale.
Luckily, smartly, the Yale Corporation
approved their petition,
and we were granted our center in 1969.
We moved into this building in 1971,
and we've been here ever since.
The House is home to over
50 student organizations,
both undergraduates, and graduate
and professional students
who are able to use our
space free of charge,
have their events here, get resources,
and get guidance from
our professional staff,
which as of right now it's just me.
Along with the 54-year
rich history of The House,
The House continues to be
mostly run by students.
So we have over 50 students
staff here and myself
with over 2,000 Black undergrads
and GMP students here at Yale.
So it's very exciting,
especially as an alum of Yale College
from the class of 2011
to be able to be here
to steward Yalies through this
space and this experience.
I welcome all of you,
and I encourage you to explore this space
once this event is over.
It is the first cultural
center on Yale's campus,
the first Black cultural
center of the Ivy League,
and one of the first Black
cultural centers in the country.
It is also the largest and, in my opinion,
the best building on this campus,
the best cultural center on this campus,
so please be sure to explore our building.
We have a library, art gallery,
meeting spaces and things,
and we are very excited
to have all of you here
for this wonderful, and very purposeful,
and timely event today.
And with that, I will pass
you off to Dean Imani.
(audience applauding)
Sorry.
- Sorry.
Thank you very much,
and thank you very much
for allowing us to host our event here
in this beautiful, beautiful
(indistinct) house,
I really feel honored to
be in this place today.
And I would like to
just welcome all of you,
good afternoon and thank you
very much for joining us today.
(object crackling* on the floor)
We're all, oh sorry (chuckles).
We're all so pleased to welcome
award-winning filmmaker Tonya Lewis Lee,
who is here with us in
this beautiful House
for this special centennial conversation.
As you know that we are celebrating
our centennial this year,
and this is a part of a
series of wonderful events
that we are going to hold
throughout this year.
I know we all look forward
to hearing about her
documentary film, "After Shock",
I hope that you have all watched
it, and her important work
in the areas of maternal
mortality and social justice.
These are two areas that
we care so much about
in the Yale School of Nursing,
and we can't wait to hear
the conversation here,
and to learn more about both areas,
and to see what could
we do as an institution
to be able to promote,
you know, social justice,
and health equity, and health justice
across the United States.
I would also would like to welcome
four of our precious Yale
School of Nursing faculty
who are going to participate
this conversation today.
Midwife and student equity
coordinator, Heather Reynolds,
nurse midwifery specialty co-directors,
Joan Combellick and Michelle Telfer.
And also last but not least,
our former interim dean
of Yale School of Nursing,
Holly Powell Kennedy,
and Helen Varney Professor of Midwifery.
(audience applauding)
I also would like to use this opportunity
to acknowledge and thank the many people
whose efforts made today's event possible,
including Tonys's team,
Michelle Koss, Mike Regan.
I think that some of you are here,
so if you are here, just
wave so that we can see you.
Taylor Testone, Peter
Plotica, Lauren Langford,
and Marsha Thomas, here.
Thank you very much.
And now it's my real pleasure
to welcome Heather Reynolds
to the podium for introducing Tonya.
(audience applauding)
(indistinct chatter)
- Oh my gosh, it's so good
to be back in this place.
(audience laughing)
I was here as a student back in the '70s,
so for me, this is like a homecoming.
I just want to say that
this incredible lady,
Tonya Lewis Lee is a
producer, film director,
writer, entrepreneur, a
woman's health advocate,
who for over 20 years has been
delivering meaningful content
that resonates with
marginalized community.
As a television producer,
Lee served as executive
producer on the Netflix series,
"She's Gotta Have It,"
it was a movie before
and then became a series.
She produced her first limited Series,
"Miracle's Boys" at Nickelodeon
based on the Jacqueline
Woodson novel of the same name,
which remains a classic today.
As a film producer, Lee produced
the adaptation of the Walter
Dean Myers novel "Monster,"
which premiered in competition
at the 2018 Sundance Film Festival
and is streaming on Netflix.
Most recently, Lee co-directed
and co-produced the Emmy nominated,
Peabody Award-Winning "After Shock,"
which we're gonna be celebrating today,
which examines the US
maternal mortality crisis.
The documentary premiered
at the 2020 Sundance Film Festival,
and won the Special Jury
Award for Impact for Change.
It was acquired by Onyx and
ABC News to release on Hulu,
in 20 July of last year.
As a writer, Tonya penned the script
for "The Watsons Go to Birmingham,"
an adaptation of the
Christopher Paul Curtis novel
that she also produced
for the Hallmark Channel.
She's the author of
three children's books,
including the classic,
"Please, Baby Please,"
as well as the adult
novel "Gotham Diaries."
She has done a lot (chuckles).
We're almost there 'cause
we want to hear from her.
In 2007, Tonya became the spokesperson for
the US Department of Health
and Human Services Office
of Minority Health Infant
Mortality Awareness Campaign,
a Healthy Baby Begins With You,
which ignited her lifelong passion
for advocating for better health outcomes
for all women in the United States,
especially women of color.
Through the campaign, Tonya produced
the film "Crisis in the Crib:
Saving Our Nation's Babies"
'cause it's not just maternal mortality,
but infant mortality too,
which is unfortunately on the rise.
This work led Tonya to
embark on her journey
as an entrepreneur to
create Movita Organics,
which is an organic
vitamin supplement brand
to continue the conversation with women
about accessing healthy outcomes,
and provide them with
a high quality resource
to aid their wellbeing
and overall vitality.
She's a member of the
Writer's Guild of America
and a member of the
Producer's Guild of America,
serving as co-chair of
the One Guide Committee
and on the Producer's
Council Board of Delegates.
She's also a member of
the Board of Trustees
of the March of Dimes,
where I'm also on their advisory council,
the Nurse's Advisory Council,
and the director emeritus
of the board of Trustees
of the NAACP Legal Defense
and Educational Fund.
In 2022, IndieWire featured Tonya
in their 22 rising female
filmmakers to watch.
She's the mother of two adult children,
and lives in New York with
her husband Spike Lee.
Welcome, it's a pleasure to
have you here, (indistinct).
(audience applauding)
(gentle music)
(tape rolling)
- My daughter's story is
loud, colorful, and artful.
- [All] It's a girl!
- She was awake, aware, and active.
Hi baby.
And yet she still died.
(suspenseful music)
- [Interviewee] After she gave birth,
Shamony was complaining
that she had really sharp chest pains.
- [Friend] The ambulance came,
I'm telling them the symptoms.
- [Nurse] Is she on drugs?
- Next set of people come
in, "Is she on drugs?"
- They kept asking her
mother, "Is she on any drug?"
- (chuckles) I'm like, "Do y'all talk?"
- We waited, a solid 12 hours.
(machine beeping)
- [Shamony] She's gone.
(dramatic percussion)
- Black women are four
times more likely to die
than their white counterparts
with the same symptoms,
why is that?
- This is a growing
epidemic in our community.
- Hundreds and thousands of men
are going through this same situation.
(suspenseful music)
♪ Well, you couldn't tell me
that I wouldn't be there. ♪
- I've never lived in
this house without her.
- You just gotta keep pushing forward.
I can't let Amber be another statistic.
♪ I had a plan ♪
♪ I had it lived out ♪
- If these numbers were flipped around,
and white women were dying
at the rate the Black women dying,
it would be a national crisis.
- [Speaker] We fight
against maternal morbidity,
event by event in order to create change.
- We can turn our pain into power,
and make something of this.
- Shamony Gibson, we hear you, we see you.
I planned on spending
a lifetime with Amber,
I wanted to give her my life.
This way, I am still going to.
♪ Sometimes change ♪
- [Megaphone Speaker] The revolution
will be Tweeted, Instagrammed, Facebooked.
- This fight is not over.
- [Megaphone Speaker]
When Black mothers die,
there's a ripple effect.
We call it "Aftershocks."
♪ Things sometimes change ♪
- Hi everybody, thank you for being here.
First, thank you so much to all of you all
who brought me here.
I am truly honored and humbled to be here
to talk to you today about "Aftershock",
and to be in conversation
with these amazing women here.
I'm gonna tell you a little
bit about how I got here
before we start the conversation,
and why I've been so passionate
about the work of maternal health,
and equalizing the
maternal healthcare here.
I think it's kind of obvious,
but I will still talk about it.
You know, one of the things
you didn't mention in that bio
is that I'm a lawyer by trade.
When I graduated from
college as a young person,
I actually really wanted
to be in the arts.
I was someone who had
studied a lot of literature,
I went to Sarah Lawrence
College, a very creative place.
I did a lot of writing
but I didn't know anyone who
had a career as a creative.
My parents were very corporate minded,
and they didn't either.
And when I said I wanted
to go into television,
they were like, "Are you crazy?"
(audience laughing)
(chuckles) "You need to get a job,
"so you can make some money."
And so I went to law
school thinking I would,
at one point thinking I would
be a civil rights lawyer.
But then again, my father was like,
"That's not what I meant when
I sent you to law school.
"I want you to make some money."
So I ended up being a corporate lawyer,
although I did clerk at the
NAACP Legal Defense Fund.
And I think my passion,
I was just talking to someone
about this the other day
for civil rights and social justice,
when I was eight years old
in the middle of third grade,
we moved from Montclair, New
Jersey to Milwaukee, Wisconsin.
And it was a traumatic
move for me in a way,
my father's company moved, so we moved.
And back in that day,
my parents were like,
"Yeah, when dad's going, we all go,"
which is great in some ways.
But moving to Milwaukee,
the suburbs of Milwaukee, Wisconsin,
I was like the second Black
student in that school.
And it was a very racist place,
and I was an 8-year-old child
being bullied by the kids,
not protected by the teachers
there, and felt very alone.
And at the end of the year, that year,
my parents transferred
me to another school.
But I bring that up because
what I think I'm trying to do
in the work that I'm doing
is fight for that little
8-year-old girl (chuckles).
I think my work is about
trying to make the world a better place,
so that other young people
don't have to go through that.
At the same time, I remember very clearly
watching the documentary
series, "Eyes on the Prize,"
these things collide to me in my mind
as an adult now, right?
"Eyes on the Prize"
was eye-opening for me,
there were these amazing civil
rights warriors out there,
fighting that fight for
all of us to have rights.
I mean, young people standing up
against dogs and water hoses,
and I think that really got
into my spirit and my soul.
And so, you know, while I
was looking to make my way
in life in some way using the things,
I was an early reader, I love stories,
I love watching movies,
I love watching TV.
And ultimately, somehow I
wanted to bring it all together
and you know, it's funny,
all of my friends were always artists.
And then I happened to marry
a super creative,
amazing artist (chuckles)
(audience laughing)
who was making it work for himself, right?
And when we got married, you know,
I talked to Spike about the fact that
I really had these creative ideas.
And he was like, "If
that's what you wanna do,
"then you should go do that,"
and really supported me in doing that.
And I started by writing, you know,
I was newly married, I gave up my job,
and I'd get up in the morning
and I'd write for hours.
And that resulted in ultimately
my first children's book,
"Please Baby, Please."
And because of "Please Baby, Please,"
and then "Please Puppy, Please,"
the US Department of
Health and Human Services
reached out to me and asked
me to be a spokesperson
for the Infant Mortality
Awareness Raising Campaign,
A Healthy Baby Begins With You.
And with that campaign I had the absolute,
I mean, blessed experience
to travel this country,
all over this country.
I was in urban areas,
I was in rural areas,
north, south, east, west, and
got a chance to meet people
where they were, the community,
people who were working in community
to try to improve outcomes.
And I got a major education,
I mean at the time,
I don't even think I at first knew
what infant mortality was,
that the US had an issue,
that Black babies were dying
at higher rates than white babies.
That it didn't matter
your socioeconomic status in this country,
as a Black person, you
still had a higher chance
of losing your child
before its first birthday.
And finding myself immersed in this world
of ultimately women's health,
because, of course, when
we talk about an infant,
we're talking about a woman's health.
I would inevitably hear stories,
not only of infant death,
but of mothers dying from
childbirth complications.
And so, as Heather mentioned,
I did a film called
Crisis in the Crib then
for the Office of Minority Health.
And I went on and
continued to do other work,
continued to travel with the campaign
because I think once your
eyes are opened in this way,
once you have the opportunity
to really get out in community
and engage with people, it
just becomes a part of you.
It certainly did for me.
I mean, I love going into community
and talking to all kinds of people.
I mean, it just fills, it fills me.
And I feel like I take them with me
and I can share them in other ways.
But then, you know, in
terms of "Aftershock" in,
I think it was 2018, Linda
wrote, Linda Villarosa
wrote a huge article
for the "New York Times"
about the US maternal mortality crisis.
And I think ProPublica did an article
and people were starting to talk about
what was happening in our
country around maternal health.
And I thought to myself,
"I better hurry up
and make a documentary about this,
'cause I wanna give my
my point of view on it
before somebody else does."
'Cause I'm gonna be really
mad if somebody else
does and they don't do it right.
So, you know, I started thinking about it
and it's a huge issue.
And I say that, I joke and say I'd be mad
if someone didn't do it right.
But the fact of the matter is,
and I know there are other
people working on documentaries,
other documentaries have
come out on the issue.
And I think it's really important
that people put their voice
to the issue the way they see it.
And for me, it was
really important to work
with somebody, to find a partner.
Because what way, there's
so many different ways in
that you can go about making this film.
And so my producing directing
partner, Paula Eiselt
and I met at a women's conference.
Someone introduced us, they
mentioned that she had,
was beginning to develop a
documentary film on the issue.
I was beginning to develop a
documentary of film on the issue.
We did not know each other.
She's a Jewish woman
who lives in New Jersey.
I am who I am.
We met one day, we had coffee another day.
And the next thing you know,
we were off making this film.
And the reason why we were off
to make this film together is
that we both had a shared
vision about how this film,
from our perspective needed to be told.
And that was centering the women
and centering the families in a way
so that first and foremost,
you humanize the issue,
because we often hear
so much about the statistics
and it's just numbers.
And so we really wanted
people to feel as hard
as it is, to feel what it means to lose
a mother from childbirth complications.
So that, that we both knew.
And at the same time, we
knew it was really important
to get the information in
about why this was happening.
We wanted to talk to experts in the field,
but we didn't want it to be a film
with just people talking at you.
We wanted you to go on a journey.
And so the way we began,
Shamony Gibson died in October, 2019.
I wanna say Paula and I met,
must have met November, 2019.
Shamony died in October.
In December, her family, her mother,
put out a call to action.
They were having an event, a celebration
of Shamony's life.
They put it on Instagram
and invited the community.
Shamony's partner, Omari wanted
to have a convening of men
to talk about what it means
as a man, as a partner
to lose someone from
childbirth complications.
Paula saw this on Instagram
'cause she's like an Instagram ninja.
I am not.
And she called Shawnee and
Shawnee answered her phone
and said, "Hey, you know,
we'd really like to come
and film what you guys are doing."
And miraculously, and
Shawnee speaks to this often,
like she really goes by
what she feels in the spirit.
And Shawnee is an amazing woman herself.
Someone who has been in the birth justice,
reproductive justice work.
As she says in the film, she knew,
she knows what these issues are.
She speaks to them often.
And yet this still
happened to her daughter.
And so I think being that
social justice warrior
that she is, she said, okay,
well I'm gonna stand up
and let the world see.
Sort of like Bruce, who
is also in the film,
his partner Amber Rose Isaac passed away.
Bruce often says that
the reason why he decided
to participate in the
film is like he thinks
about Mamie Till.
Till when Emmett Till was
brutally murdered, Mamie decided
to open up the casket, have an open casket
to show his mutilated
body so everyone could see
what happened to her son.
And so for Bruce opening up
himself to us as filmmakers,
to all of us to see his story
as like opening up the casket
so we can see what he went through,
so maybe we learned something.
And so, you know, Shawnee
was really the beginning.
Omari says that at first, he was like,
there's no way he was gonna do this film.
You know, he was two months into his grief
and Shawnee too, I mean,
very early in their grief.
But they let us, they let us come in
and they let us go through
the process with them.
After, so Omari had
the first men's circle.
There were some other
fathers who had lost there.
So then Amber Rose Isaac
died in April of 2020.
Omari hears, because this is now,
they're on a network, right?
So, so these men now,
or these families, they hear
of someone else, someone died.
Omari reaches out to Bruce,
they develop a relationship.
And because Omari
and Bruce have this relationship,
Omari explains to Bruce,
we're making this film.
And Bruce says, "Okay,
I am gonna go get on."
But I will tell you before that, Bruce,
after I wanna say, so
if Amber died in April,
I wanna say it was maybe even two weeks
after Amber died, Bruce
had a press conference,
which we actually filmed
before we knew Bruce,
because we had heard again on social media
that he was gonna have
this press conference.
So we brought out a camera to capture him
doing his press conference.
And thereafter we met him
and continued on the journey with them.
And I, I'll say, you
know, I make this film
because like I said before,
it seems obvious to me.
Infants, mothers, you
know, that is the bedrock,
the health of women,
the health of infants is
the health of a nation.
That's how you mark
And we are not doing well at all.
And we should be doing better.
And so I made this film
because I wanna make an impact.
I mean, when you hear
my bio, like I'm trying
to make an impact.
I'm trying to humanize
one, the Black experience,
because I know as a young Black child
what it's like to be dehumanized.
So we wanna humanize our
experience for ourselves
and for all of us so we
understand who we are
and so that we can and
we can come together.
And I also have to say like my partnership
with Paula in making this
film, I mentioned she
and I are very different.
We have very different points of view
and it can be very difficult
to have hard conversations about things.
She doesn't understand my life experience.
I don't understand her life experience.
That can create conflict.
But I think it's really
important that we dig down
and have those conversations.
I think when we are made
to feel most uncomfortable
sometimes the places
where we grow the most.
And so as we made this very
difficult, complicated film,
you know, we also learned
and grew from each other.
And it's really my hope that
"Aftershock" is able to,
and that's why it's so amazing
to be here with you all today.
Because I think, you
know, as, as people go on
and their lives and
their careers, I'm hoping
that "Aftershock" stays in
someone's brain a little bit.
And especially healthcare
providers, to think about
how you are treating someone
and how you can have a real impact.
We all have an impact I mean,
and I believe we all have a role to play
in making this crisis better.
And for me it's by
storytelling and by standing up
and by giving voice to
what I can give voice to.
And I'm humbled by the ability to do that.
And for you, it may be
something, something different,
but that's why I am here.
That's what motivates
me to make "Aftershock"
and to do the other kinds
of work that I'm working on.
I will always be advocating
for women and infants' health.
It is of the most
important thing we can do.
When I saw the, just this morning
or yesterday, the fact
that our infant mortality
rate is going up,
it's like WTF, how can this be?
How are we not as a nation putting all
of our resources to our people?
I just, I, it just,
because we are supposed to
be the beacon for the world.
And yet, and yet we have
these abysmal rates.
It's, and it's solvable.
It's not like we can't fix it.
We can, if we choose to.
So I will continue to be
fighting and thank you.
And I look forward to our conversation.
(audience applauding)
- See the young leading
the old. (laughing)
Thank you. (laughing)
Yeah, thank you so much.
Those words of wisdom
and how we can move to
beyond just feeling to doing
and making an impact.
It's so important.
You know, I look at the healthcare system
in the United States
and the structural racism
that exists is so pervasive
and so destructive to particularly
to marginalized communities
with Black mothers
and indigenous women having
the worst outcomes in terms
of not only infant mortality,
but also maternal mortality.
And I wonder, you know, if we need
to start looking at the
health profession schools as
where we need to put our energies,
because these systems are
so entrenched, you know,
whether or not they're gonna
change quickly enough to
make the dramatic changes that we need
to see in the lives of these families.
Whether or not we need
to start putting some
of our energies into transforming
and educating people in the
health profession schools
in a way that they become more
appropriate, less, you know,
influenced by racial, you
know, beliefs or whatever,
so that we can ultimately
change those structures
to better accommodate
and care for women, particularly
those who are marginalized.
So I guess my question is,
should we then be putting
a lot more emphasis
or focus on those health
profession schools,
not only in creating a
diverse body of, of providers,
but also educating all of the providers so
that they can make changes
within the systems?
- Yeah, absolutely.
I think, I think first of
all, building the pipeline.
I think we were, you know,
somehow, I don't know if
that was you guys, but I
think first of all, I mean,
and that's down the line,
but building a pipeline
of healthcare providers,
looking at young people from,
I mean like going really young,
like getting them interested
and excited about the
sciences and healthcare
and healthcare and community
and helping them find connectivity ways.
And I know places like Robert Wood Johnson
are doing things like that,
but I think we need more
and more of that reaching
to reaching out to our Black
and brown youngsters to get them involved
in healthcare providing.
For those that are already there,
they're absolutely, I
mean it's just amazing.
Even some of the way
people are taught recently,
someone showed me a campaign
called Illustrate Change.
I don't know if you all are
familiar with this, with just
to show images in textbooks of medical
textbooks of people who are brown.
Like it's 2023.
And you mean to tell me
that in textbooks we're really
still just seeing mostly just
white people and things show
up differently on brown skin.
So just integrating the way,
just naturally things flow
through so it's not so obscure or odd.
I also think, it seems
to me that even the way
the medical profession teaches
it's hard on doctors, right?
You're dehumanized yourself
and so you're rushed
through, you gotta hurry up,
you gotta do, you can't
eat, you gotta grind.
And I think often that
kind of dehumanization
if you will, of the healthcare
providers ends up trickling
down often to the patient as well.
So is there a more humane way about
going about the teaching?
Now I know it's a stressful
job, don't get me wrong,
but I just think that
there's gotta be a way
that people, and I,
I mean this is the hardest
work though, right?
I mean, how do you teach empathy?
I mean, that's a hard thing to teach.
People again, come with life experience
before they get there.
You know, we live in a
white supremacist society
that is driving you in a certain place.
It's, it has to be active
work to change that mindset.
So I do think institutions really
need to be thinking about that.
And I, I'll end this by
saying, as we all know,
when you solve the problem
for the most marginalized
and most vulnerable, you
solve it for everyone.
And by the way, nobody's
doing all that well compared
to other industrialized nations.
- I have a question or
two, but before I ask that,
I wanna say thank you to you
for also allowing the school
of nursing and our nursing
and midwifery students and faculty
and staff to kind of be
in your glow for a while
and have you here amongst us.
So it is very special for us.
Along the lines of the
educational pipeline,
three of us here are
actually on the admissions
committee this year.
And I would like your opinion
of the recent Supreme Court decision
that enforces race blind admissions
and how you think that
will impact our ability
to diversify ethnically,
culturally, racially our workforce,
which has been a priority
of the Yale School
of Nursing historically.
And it's very present
for us at this moment
as we're beginning to
receive applications.
- Yeah, I can, I can only
imagine what it's like
working in these institutions with
that decision coming down.
First, I feel like,
the numbers weren't
that high to begin with.
Let's start with that. Right?
Let's just be clear.
I just want to say that
it's not like, you know,
there were lots of Black and
brown people coming through
and so, you know, this
decision is stopping the flood
of unqualified Black and brown people.
That is just BS. We know that, right?
So I think, I think it's interesting.
I wonder how, I know you all
are under a lot of pressure
and I wonder what the impact will be.
I have to say I call
out Edward Bloom by name
because this is a campaign
directed by a person that is not
who is, who has other people behind him.
Don't get me wrong, he's not the only one.
But there is a person who is on a mission
to take things away from Black
and brown people, including women.
And I have to, you mentioned
the affirmative action,
I'm gonna get back to
school, but he also came
after the Fearless
Fund, if you don't know,
which is a venture fund
that supports Black
and brown women looking
to have their own economic independence.
They only give $20,000 per entrepreneur
and he wants to stop that
when we get like such a tiny
amount of funding from venture funds.
So I say that to say
there is an assault coming
to, and it's amazing because
the numbers are so small.
So what are you, what
are they so afraid of?
You know, in some ways I
look and I say, well gosh,
Black and brown women must
be doing something right.
You know, we, we must be a
force to be reckoned with.
And I guess Trump would tell you
that too when he looks
at who's prosecuting him.
But, sorry, that's an aside.
You know, I think you all have a challenge
and I think, I think your
challenge again goes to
what happens before
the admissions process.
And I don't know what
you can do about that,
but I feel like there
needs again to, you need
to start way earlier,
getting young people ready
to get here, get excited, and be here
and be able to be
admitted in the right way.
And I think that's what's
gonna have to change.
I also think you're gonna
have to be crafty, you know?
You know, I don't, I can't remember
what it's like applying to grad school.
It was so long ago that I did.
But really like looking
at who the whole person is
and understanding who that person is
and really making sure they're
supported once they get here.
I mean, I think that's the other thing.
I mean, you know, it's
one thing to be admitted,
it's another thing to make it through.
And people really need a lot
of support when they are here.
So I think you're up against
a lot of challenges right now.
It's a tough time and for
those of you who are here,
I mean it, you're in a battle.
I mean, you're on the
front, I mean this is
frontline battle stuff.
Put your armor on 'cause
they're gonna keep coming.
They might, you know, you got here,
you're getting through it.
I'm sure there, there are complications
and difficulties while you're here
and they're gonna be when you get outta
here, wherever you go after that.
So put your armor on,
get your battle gear,
make sure you've got the people
around you that support you
and understand what you're doing
because it doesn't get easier.
And don't give up because
you're doing something right,
because that's why
they're trying to stop us.
- Would it be okay if
I just ask our nursing
and midwifery students to
stand up that are here?
Would you guys be up to, be up to that?
(audience applauding)
- I'm excited to see them.
I just, I just wanna really thank you
for doing what you're doing.
It's really important work.
So, so thank you and
thank you for being here.
- My second question is,
if you can talk about this,
what's your next equity related project
that you're thinking about working on?
Where are you going from here?
- Very different kind of project.
I've done some heavy stuff.
I did, as you heard, I,
I made the film "Monster"
before this, which is about
a 17 year-old kid who's
incarcerated for his part in a robbery
and then did "Aftershock".
So what I'm working on right now is,
and I don't know if it'll
actually see the light
of day, but I'm working on it.
It's a script that is a feature film,
that's horror, that deals a little bit
with, well I'll just
tell you, it's, you know,
the land in Martha's Vineyard.
I think a lot of people think
of Martha's Vineyard
these days as one thing.
What it is, it's funny, if
you Google Martha's Vineyard,
it begins, the story of
Martha's Vineyard begins
with white people
showing up on the shores.
Like there were not
indigenous people there
who have been there since 20,000 BC.
So I'm having a little
bit of fun trying to,
and I, you know, of course I'm making it
so complicated for myself.
My son is like, I don't know
why you're working so hard.
Look at all that crap on Netflix.
I don't know why, you know,
but I wanna say something about, you know,
the land and the trauma
and the fact that what happened
before we're still
dealing with today in ways
that we don't even understand.
And you know, again, just, you know,
trying to write something that's kind of
surprising in the fact
that I'm actually dealing
with something that's really important.
- So we talked a little
bit about this in the car
that there's a framework
of quality maternal-
The battery doesn't work.
Can you hear me now? Oh yeah.
There's a framework on quality maternal
and newborn care that's
based on evidence that was
produced 10 years ago on,
particularly around midwifery.
And it, and it has five
components that look at
how we practice, who practices,
who the workers are, how the
practices based in values
and philosophy and how it's organized.
Can women get to it? Can they,
is it acceptable to them?
So those pretty well make up
all the things that all women
and newborns should have.
So if you had one area to invest in
that you think would make the most impact,
what would you invest in?
- I am laughing because
she asked me this question
earlier, not quite like that.
And I said in my, she was like,
if there's one thing I could
have, what would it be?
And I said, Jeff Bezos' money.
And so now, now she's like, okay,
so if you had Jeff Bezos money,
what would be the one thing
that you would invest in?
You know, I, the reason
why it's hard for me
to answer it like that is
because this is a multi-pronged problem.
And so you need a multi-pronged approach.
That is, to me, the crux of the problem.
Everyone keeps trying to go to one thing.
Like if I just go to the community
and I do this, then the
problem will be solved.
And that's why I resist
answering it like that.
And I say I need a lot of money so
that I can put money towards politics so
that we can affect policy,
we can elect good people into
office that who are going to
put forth the kind of
policies like making sure
that all women get postpartum
care that is covered,
that we can make sure that all
women can get midwifery care.
What I would do is I would, I would try
to help the midwives
get their act together.
I love midwives.
I don't mean that in a a pejorative,
I think midwives are amazing,
but what I mean by that is
really help build, you know,
a truly robust midwifery
program in the United States.
I mean, the fact that
we're the only country,
the only industrialized country
that does not have midwifery
care integrated into our
healthcare system is insane to me.
And so I would really try to
figure out how to do that.
How to, I mean, I would,
I would invest in,
at HBCU getting midwifery programs started
and going, going even younger
talk, you know, programs
that get young people thinking
about midwifery programs,
investing in more birthing
centers, again, state by state.
So I gotta deal with the
politics to get that happening.
But I do think that midwifery
care is a huge answer
and I think that helping to fund them
and bring them together and set them up
for success would be, would be
a huge, huge in this country.
- Sorry, I have my words here
'cause I'm a little nervous.
No, this is, thank you for
being here and letting us, yeah.
Just be with you here.
If you feel comfortable
speaking personally,
what was the impact of
making this film on you?
And as you hold all that
was in that film, I just,
it's like what and what,
how do you find the strength
to kind of keep moving
forward with this work?
I mean, you've been doing it a
while and to just keep going?
- Yeah, I have to say that Shawnee, Omari
and Bruce are amazing human beings who
lost and picked up.
And because I look at,
I look at them obviously never
having met Shamony or Amber,
and I can see what loving,
loved on beautiful
spirits these women were.
And I see that
because their families hold them up
on the work that they do.
And you know, I say that, you
know, if Shawnee can get up
and do the work, I
certainly can't be laying on
the floor crying about it.
I need to get up and help support her
and any way that I, any way that I can.
And so the impact on
me, I mean, it is hard.
I, you know, I hadn't seen,
I just saw the film again last week
after having not seen it for a while.
And you know, it's hard.
But then I look at Omari
and I look at Shawnee
and I look at Bruce
today, I mean, we met them
so early in their grief.
First of all, they look different,
right? Grief is physical.
And so they look different.
They're doing amazing work.
The children are thriving.
And so honestly, I feel
somewhat empowered.
There were times though, I,
no, no, I mean, it was hard.
I mean, you know, there are
other people that we talked to
and you know, I try to be so professional.
I will say like, you, you
really do steel yourself, right?
Like, I'm gonna be a professional.
I'm not gonna show emotion.
But I remember talking to
some mother, another father
and him explaining the death of his wife
and just, I felt so bad
because I just broke.
I broke down and he's there
saying to me, "It's okay".
And I'm like, no, it's not
your job to comfort me.
It's my job to comfort you. You know?
But, and also, you know,
when I look at people like Helena Grant,
who's a midwife in the
film, who gave us a lot
of information and Neel Shah
and I look at the history
that, that we've been through,
I will say I'm just grateful, honestly.
I'm just really grateful and
I know it was a blessing.
I know this was a blessing.
I was where I was supposed
to be in the right place at
the right time to do the work.
And I'm sit back now
and I'm like, oh my God, I
can't believe we did that.
It feels so easy now that you're
out of it. But it was hard.
It was really, really
hard in a lot of ways.
And doing it, I worked out,
I kept myself working out,
I kept myself eating really well.
I kept boundaries with the team so
that we could do the work
and not get completely overtaken by it.
Because it is, it is tough, hard stuff.
(audience applauding)
- (speaking faintly) Students
at Yale School of Nursing.
My question is, with the
aftermath of the film,
since it did take place in New York City,
which has such a high
disparity between Black
and white mothers or birth
persons, did any politicians
or any community workers,
did anyone reach out to you
about legislative change
after watching the film?
- I really appreciate that question.
In fact, yesterday I just
had a debriefing with
a few deputy mayors, the
Department of Health,
a lot of people in New York.
And a couple of months ago I met with two
of the deputy mayors,
well the deputy mayor
and another deputy mayor,
two Black women who sat down
with me and said, "We
want our legacy to be
that we've improved the outcomes
or at least put things in
place to improve outcomes."
So it is coming, I think
this morning I think,
or last night there was,
oops, there was just
announced like a healthy,
healthy New York.
And within that there is a
cutout from maternal health.
And so yes, they have reached out.
They do know how bad it is.
And I think especially these
Black women deputy mayors
want to leave office
whenever that may be, knowing
they've done what they can
for Black and brown
women in New York City.
- Hi, good afternoon panel.
I'm also a student in the DNP program
and of course I've shared with you
before that I've shown your
film a number of times.
I think what's important
that I wanted to piggyback on
that you said earlier was the
fact that the issues as far
as things being preventable,
the maternal health issues
being preventable is like right
here in Connecticut too,
as the program director
of maternal health equity,
there's a maternal mortality
review committee right here in
Connecticut that says 80% of the deaths
that occur could have been prevented.
So I just wanted to bring it on home so
that it's not a matter of
looking from just a national lens
of where we are with these
statistics and these numbers,
but knowing that this is hitting
really close to home in a,
really, in a way that we can improve on.
- Thank you for that. Thank
you. And and you're right.
I mean, 80% are preventable.
And then, you know,
the other thing that I,
that I often don't talk about when I just
mention is the near deaths.
You know, how many women nearly die
from childbirth complications?
That's not even caught in that number.
- Hello, my name is Jenny Rebecca.
I'm a nurse midwifery
student here. Brooklynite.
- -[Tonya] Brooklyn's in The House.
- Before I came here, I was
a doula for about six years.
And the first birth I went to, I was,
I realized I wanted to be a midwife.
So I went back to school, did nursing.
And it's interesting because this film,
it was hard for me to watch.
It took four or five goes
because these were the
people I worked with.
The Black women in New York
were the ones that would come to me
and the doula was the answer.
And then as like time went
on, the doula was the bandaid,
and then the midwife was the
bandaid for this problem.
And working with the Black
woman I did who, you know,
had doctorates from Harvard
and, you know, had three like degrees
and were making like this much money.
And they would always tell me like, am I,
like they would say that to
their provider in front of me.
And it's like, that's, that's
not enough. It doesn't matter.
And to have been on that side as a doula
and an advocate was hard
because you watch just like
all those sly little things
that do happen and how people do like
fall through the cracks.
And then becoming a
nurse, I was more aware
and I understood how the systems work.
And now being here, having
the education that I do, like,
I'm well aware that we are
oppressed when we are on
labor and birth floors.
And I don't wanna be one
of the providers that doesn't listen.
And I truly do believe that we have
to like dismantle these systems
like the way hospitals work,
the way healthcare like, like
insurance is like the bane
of all of like, how we
have these problems.
Like Medicare gets cut off,
like Medicaid gets cut off
as soon as post for postpartum.
And it's like, one of the
reasons I came here is
because I knew that we
have to change education
and like, I think before
my last breath, I want
to like change the way we're
taught about maternal mortality
and how we're taught about
obstetric care in textbooks.
And I guess like when I look
at films like this, you know,
I want the people that are
making decisions for care
and do these like, you know, ethic
and bias workshops in their hospitals
to actually really understand
like it's the smallest little
moment to stop and not have
35 patients on your roster
and say, can I stop for
this one person to listen
that shortness of breath
or the pain in their chest
or the pain in their arm
that doesn't quite line up
with preeclampsia and
maybe that's what it is.
And to like not worry about
what things cost to send someone
in for a workup.
And it's like, it's frustrating
'cause now I see every
single side of this problem
and then the weathering
and then systemic racism
and this going back over 200 years
and yeah, I, maybe it's just an echo
of what everyone's has said so far,
but being on the side,
it's like you really
realize the importance
and it's the word that you
used to steel yourself.
Like that's the only way to like,
but I'm getting through
this to figure out like,
how can I be effective without
being on the floor crying.
- Yeah, thank you for that.
You know, as I listen to
you talk, I think about it,
I know you, I know you
all know Jenny Joseph,
I've had the opportunity to
be with her and hear her speak
and one of the things that, you know, I
so appreciate about her is
she's so blunt and direct
and she's like, I'm tired of
talking about the problem.
Now I need to build a system
outside of the system.
Like, like that is what she's thinking.
And like, it's like how
do we do that? Like that?
That's the thing, right?
But again, you know, you,
you think about that, right?
Okay, we're gonna build
it outside of the system
so women don't have to deal.
But then in places like Alabama
where the outcomes in
hospitals were terrible
and the midwives and the
community said, you know what?
We're gonna build
outside of the community.
We're gonna build outside of the system.
We're gonna set up our
own midwifery practice.
Black women are like, great,
we're gonna come there.
And then the state comes
and gets in their business
and says, oh no, you can't do that.
We want you all to go to hospitals,
but our outcomes are better.
So you say you wanna protect women,
but you're gonna send us
back into the hospital
where the outcomes are worse.
So what are you really,
oh, you're policing
women is what, what you're doing.
You don't want us to figure it out.
So it's, I mean, it is, it's hard.
It's really hard and really
frustrating, which is again,
why I need Jeff Bezos' money so I can help
get better politicians in Alabama
so I can support those women
who are setting up their birthing centers.
- Good evening. My name is Tamika.
I'm part of the YSN faculty
here at the School of Nursing.
And I had, bear with me, I'm gonna try
to do this without getting emotional.
I had my first maternal
experience three months ago when I
gave birth to, at 24
weeks to a micro preemie.
My daughter, her name is Marissa,
she's still at Yale New Haven Hospital,
neonatal intensive care unit.
And when I think about
how infant mortality is
deeply rooted in systemic
and structural racism, I know
and I understand that I have a Black baby
that's being taken care of by
a predominantly white healthcare team.
And I have lost sleep over that.
'Cause she cannot talk, she
cannot advocate for herself.
And it's something that I
worry about every single day.
Now, don't get me wrong,
the team has been amazing.
All the nurses and doctors I, you know,
had a good experience so far.
But it's something that
it, it's statistics
and it's the facts
that I'm there every day at her bedside,
trying to have a voice and advocate.
I'm there. They know me by my first name.
I'm always there when they're
rounding on her talking
about her medical care.
But it's something that's like,
it's my life right now being
her voice, being there,
speaking up, asking questions,
and you know, giving birth
is just one part of it.
It now translates to
making sure she, you know,
she has complications of
course being born at 24 weeks.
But, you know, just being there
and making sure like are
we doing the right things
and just being involved in her care.
So, you know, I think it, yes,
the diversity is so important
that we are starting at
diversifying the healthcare force
and having more diverse midwives
and starting with admissions committee
and, you know, enrolling
more healthcare workers of,
you know, more diverse backgrounds
and how important that is
to see, you know, nurses
and doctors who are of
color that can relate
to our lived experiences.
And it's just so important
because we are taking care of patients
and this is the community
and this is the population
that deserve to have, you know,
people that look like us.
- God bless you, God bless Marissa.
And how are you doing?
- Good.
- You're doing okay?
Because I know, I know
we're worried about Marissa,
but you know, you gotta
be okay too, right?
And I understand how you feel.
That's a scary thing leaving your child
with strangers who don't look like you.
And yet here you are, you're
a, you're a nursing student,
so, so you know the things
to say, the language to use
to let them know that, you know, right?
Imagine, and that's a
blessing and it's still scary.
Imagine you didn't have that.
You're coming from a
totally different place
and you can't even talk
the talk, which again,
you being able to talk the
talk, you hope that helps,
helps them help you better.
No one should have to go through that.
Like this is, this is the part
that makes me crazy, you know?
But I really appreciate you
sharing that and I wish you
and Marissa all the best
and you know, I wish you
the best in your career
as well as you go forward.
Oh, well I pity those nurses
if they don't get it right.
(group laughing)
- That's why I said they
know me by the first name.
(group laughing)
- Anyone else?
Don't be shy.
- So I would like to thank you very much
for your thought provoking, you know,
experience that you shared with us.
And also thank you, all of you
for your very good questions.
I just want to, you know,
reiterate what you all,
you know, alluded to,
and I think that we need
to really pause and thinking
about what you said, you know,
that mortality rate, infant mortality rate
and maternal mortality rates
are raising in this
country that, you know,
they are rising in this country
and they are preventable.
Another thing that I wanted
to add to it that is,
that makes it even more outrageous is that
US spend almost five times more
in healthcare services than
any other, you know,
high income countries.
So it's, it's not only about, you know,
how much money do we use in,
to provide healthcare services.
And the problem is that those, you know,
high rates are not seen
in the white population.
So that means that there is
nothing else that is, you know,
causing this problem then
racism, nothing else.
And we need to call it out
and we need to talk about it
and we need to act on it
because I think that that
is, I cannot, you know,
it is outrageous for me to
just as a healthcare provider
and healthcare educator to just see
that happening year out and year in.
And we cannot, you know, that not only
that we cannot stop it,
but it's, you know, increasing constantly.
And that is so important
for our next generation
of healthcare providers here, our midwives
and other, you know, nurses
that we are graduating that
really we need to become the advocate
and we need to do something
about be being the voice of our,
you know, the, the people who
otherwise don't, don't have voice and that
is just horrific.
- Yeah, I appreciate that comment.
We had, we had a scene that,
that we had to take out
of the film that was a
group of midwives talking
around a table about their experience.
And one of the things, and
they are, they work in hospital
and a couple of them were saying,
one in particular said
they think of themselves
as the guardian at the gate
as being midwives in
the hospital system so
that when they see behaviors that are
racist or traumatic to
a patient, they will go
and try to correct that behavior.
I think you're a 100% right,
we have to call it out.
You know, the problem is that
those of us in this room,
we may, you know, we, we, and
I believe in anti-racist work
and I, but there are moments
when it's very hard for me,
I get very cynical
because I, you know, as this
country seems to be moving in,
I don't know what this crazy
direction we're moving in,
people don't seem to really care.
They don't care about
Black people, straight up.
They just don't care about Black people.
And so I try to think of it like,
and I often will say, well,
even if you don't care about Black people,
you should care about this issue
because it's coming for you.
You know, if you fix it early,
like in the, like the, like
drug crisis, if in the '80's
instead of vilifying people
because they had crack addictions
and calling them crack
heads and locking them up
and you know, treating them
poorly, maybe by the time we got
to this opiate situation
we would be a little better
prepared to deal with it, you know?
But people don't learn.
And again, white supremacy
is a very white supremacy.
Our paternalistic society,
they're very powerful
and people are not trying
to give it up, you know,
but to your point, we
do have to call it out
and we do have to fight as much as we can
and we have to be slick and we have
to call out people like Edward Bloom
and we have to figure out
how we go up against him
and his cohorts as well.
- Thank you so much for the
film and for doing this today.
I'm curious, the process
of getting to midwifery and
in particular birth center
and community-based midwifery
is such a theme in this,
and whether that came out of
like Bruce and Amber's story
because they had sought that out,
or if it was sort of in
your mind to begin with
because that's, you know,
the world that I'm in
and I can see it very
clearly that a big part
of the solution to this
is community-based care
and community birth.
But the reality is
that's a very white world
and that's not what, you know,
Black people are accessing
or even necessarily trying
to access in a lot of
parts of the country.
And so, you know, when I
advocate for, you know,
community birth as part of
the solution to health equity,
I often hear like, you know,
that's not necessarily true
or how do you know, or whatever.
So I guess I'm just asking
you, how did you know
and how did that become such a,
such a theme in the, in the film?
- Yeah, I, I don't know.
I feel like the, the Black folks in
that I came across really
do advocate for that kind
of community birthing.
For us, you're right.
With Bruce and Amber,
it was a midwife who saw
that her platelets were
dropping, who sent her
to actually to the hospital
for care when she realized
she couldn't care for her.
We also went down to
Tulsa, Oklahoma, as you saw
with Neel Shah, and met up
with a Tulsa Birth Equity Initiative,
which is providing doula care down there.
Also, separately, we had
heard about Helena Grant
doing amazing work at
Woodhull Hospital as the head
of the midwifery program there.
And so, you know, I think just, you know,
getting into the world, you
know, we were just hearing lots
of different things that were going on.
And I think, you know, I do
think that there, I mean,
Shamony had a midwife
at one point. She did.
And so we were hearing
about midwives talking
to people about, you know,
I think we know this,
we gotta save ourselves.
And so the community is
trying to figure it out
and everyone's talking.
And then when we went down to
Tulsa, I mean, that was just,
you know, meeting the people at Tulsa
Birth Equity Initiative,
a doula program down there
that connected us with
Felicia, who's the woman
that gave birth in the film,
who really thought she was gonna give
birth for, with a doctor.
We, and she just decided
at the last minute
to do something else.
Those women actually,
the, the, the, the head of
that birthing center
actually is indigenous.
And so, you know, the
community is really trying
to do the work to protect themselves
and come up with solutions to themselves.
And I think that's how,
that's how we found them.
Oh, and I do wanna say too,
Neel Shah, to his credit,
the doctor in the film from
Harvard also has worked,
works a lot with midwives and so,
and I appreciate him and
I do wanna shout him out
for this because as a
obstetrician gynecologist,
he really is an advocate
for midwifery care.
And I think that's really important
because having doctors
who understand the role
that midwives play, I
think is really critical.
Understanding that it's not that,
that everybody can work
together is really critical.
And Neil was really, is
really fantastic in that way.
- [Emcee] Any other questions?
You sure?
- (speaking faintly) Future generation
to make credible changes
and your work is contributing
so much to informing public
and us about where we need
to go, what we need to do.
So thank you for being
here and I appreciate it.
Well, thank you for having me.
And this is how we do it, right?
Like, we come together, we
have these conversations.
I know I feel full from this conversation,
from all the work that you all are doing.
And as I said, I take it with me and I,
and I hope we all leave here
and keep having conversations
with each other, with other people.
I will say the one thing,
you know, that I think is
so important, and we've touched on here
is a cultural shift in
how we think about
birthing in this country.
Birth is a sacred process.
It is a natural process.
No one is sick. It is an amazing process.
And when you birth a baby
and you go through that labor,
as Felicia says in the film,
it's the hardest thing she's ever done.
She knows she can do anything.
And that's why we're so oppressed in it.
Because if women really, if we're able
to realize our full power,
for those of us who choose
to give birth, oh my god,
these men wouldn't know,
wouldn't know what to do with us.
So they're trying to keep us tamped down.
But I think, I think we
all need to think about,
and I know I'm talking, I'm
preaching to the choir here,
but like how we talk about
birth, I mean, as you see,
I don't use the word delivery.
I, no one delivered, no
doctors delivered a baby.
Women do the work. They birth a baby.
A baby is birthed here.
And I think if we can
think about birthing as,
and again, it's all about choice.
If I choose to give birth,
how I choose to give birth,
where I choose to give birth,
a woman has a choice in all
of these things, who I
choose to birth with.
When, when you start getting
that kind of language around,
when we start talking to
young people about, you know,
and we should talk to young
people about birthing, like,
I don't know why it's such
a mystery all the time.
It's an amazing process.
We all had to go through it to get here.
And we've been doing it
since the times of ancient.
It's amazing.
So I think I'll just end
with saying like, I just,
my hope is that, and not
necessarily this project
that I mentioned before, but as we go on,
that we really think about
birthing as the amazing, sacred,
awesome thing that those of us who choose
to do it can do it.
And hopefully that that helps people
change the way we do it as well.
(audience applauding)
- I would like to, once
again, thank you very much for
your activism and
everything that you do to be
the voice of voiceless.
And and thank you very
much for coming here
and I, we can talk about, you know,
speak for everyone here that
I think that this was really,
you know, pro thought provoking
and I know that we are
leaving here with a lot
of thoughts in our, you know,
mind to continue this work.
It's very important. Thank you so much.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you so much. Thank you.
(bright music)